can we return
to dogs sure
no no no no no no no
the other ones categorically forbidden
get categorized but
is there any cryptocurrency based on
cats actually i i think there are like
was
there was cat coin there was neon coin
for some reason they just didn't catch
on as much as
the dog coins did okay so let's talk
about dogecoin and elon musk
elon said that quote ideally
doge speeds up block time 10x
increases block size 10x and drops
fee 100x then it wins
hands down end quote you said
in a blog post partially responding to
that
that there are subtle technical reasons
why this is not possible
to this elon said that you quote
fear the doge uh so let's talk about
this
what are the technical uh hurdles for
dogecoin that prevent it from becoming
one of the primary
cryptocurrencies of the world and do you
in fact
fear the doge i definitely feel
obligated to correct the record i
definitely do not fear the doge okay no
i love the doge
um i actually visited the doge in japan
a few years back it's uh
she's an amazing dog he's still alive
wait the original doge yeah
oh wow um
so you know we accept doge every
every year for our annual def con
conferences
um so i definitely you know don't think
ethereum is opposed to dot coins i
mean i kind of i kind of wants to feel
like you know ethereum is at least a
little bit in spirit itself a dog coin
and then you know as i'm
as i mentioned you know i love doge i
bought but i bought a bunch of dos i
still hold some a bunch of dosh
the on the scalability question like the
challenge basically is like
the limits uh scalability as a and the
trade-offs with centralization right
like if you
just increase the parameters without
doing anything else then it just becomes
more and more difficult for people to
validate the chain and it
just becomes more likely that the chain
becomes centralized and
becomes vulnerable to all kinds of
capture so does it need like
some of the layer two technologies that
we've been talking about
um i mean i personally think that you
know if doge wants to
somehow bridge through ethereum and then
people can trade doge thousands of times
a second inside of
loopring then you know that would be
amazing i mean if they want to just like
take zk roll up style technology and
just have thousands of transactions a
second on their own chain then that's um
you know that would be a great outcome
as well so what is there ways for
ethereum
and uh deutsche coin to work together so
okay so there there's a power behind a
person like elon musk
pushing the development of a
cryptocurrency
is there ways to leverage that power and
that momentum
to improve ethereum to improve some of
the
sort of uh cryptocurrencies that are
already technologically advanced and
pushing forward
that kind of technology i i definitely
think there is
room for you know that uh there's that
meme of doge like
taking over like that's the door i've
seen it is there a way to ride that
uh that storm that wave of the doge
has taken over i think if we could have
a secure doshu ethereum bridge then
you know that would be amazing and then
when ethereum gets its scalability
any scalability thing that works for
ethereum assets you would be able to
also like
trade wrapped doors with extremely low
transaction fees and very high speed as
well
is there uh is there precedence for
building secure bridges between
cryptocurrencies
is that i mean how difficult is this
kind of task that's it's definitely
something that's in its
infancy there definitely have been some
cross-chain interaction things that have
been done before um so one the earliest
is probably the concept of merge mining
right when
a chain just makes its entire um a
proof-of-work algorithm dependent on
the proof-of-work algorithm of another
chain and so i think famous
doshcoin actually merged mines to
litecoin which is i think in retrospect
it's not looking like a very good choice
because now
deutsche coin is bigger than litecoin um
but
um you know if there's potentially some
way for
dogecoin to merge mine with an ethereum
proof of stake ins of some kinds then
like that could be an interesting
alternative um
if so that's one type of like chain
interaction
as far as like bridges like one chain
reading another chain
early in ethereum's history there was
this project called btc relay
it's a smart contract on ethereum that
just verifies bitcoin blocks
i think uh people stopped really caring
about and maintaining it because there
just weren't enough
applications that were actually
interested in using it at the time and
then the transaction fees got too high
to actually maintain it
so i i think if we want to make a btc
relay 2.0
and that becomes cheaper because you
know it uses snarks or something like
that then you probably could
but and maybe now is the time when you
actually
like can do that sort of one-way
verification but the one challenge
though is that
if he wants to have a bridge that allows
you to move assets between chains
then you don't just need one-way
verification you need two-way
verification
right and ethereum can verify anything
because ethereum smart contracts can
just run arbitrary code
but if you want bitcoin to be able to do
things based on what happens in ethereum
lands then
bitcoin would have to basically well
they can do everything with soft forks
because like
you know that that's their religion but
no th they'll do it that way
and if doge wants to make a fork where
that allow allows for a two-way
transferability with ethereum then you
know they could i mean i i think that
would be
a lovely collaboration to make if
there's interest
i think there might actually even be
some multi-sig funds that have some
some funding it's just a bounty for
someone to make a bridge between the two
oh could you maybe try to psychoanalyze
elon musk for a brief second
so what are your thoughts about tesla
and elon musk's
journey through the cryptocurrency world
so
first with bitcoin and then with
doshcoin so acquiring a large
acquiring holding a large amount of
bitcoin and i believe
at least considering the acquiring and
holding a large amount of doshcoin
positive as negatives what do you think
the future for tesla and spacex
in the cryptocurrency space looks like
do you think they'll consider ethereum
um i'm i'm sure that if you know they
stay in
the the cryptocurrency ecosystem at all
then they have to at some point
yeah you know bitcoin number one
dogecoin number i mean you know come on
it deserves to be number three
and then or number two and then ethereum
can be whatever that uh
whatever that other number is um but um
the well if ethereum only becomes a dot
coin somehow maybe change the logo to
incorporate
uh a dog of some sort almost like doors
like
uh sneaking behind oh that would be that
would be fascinating
and i think like elon you definitely
i think you would make a mistake if you
were to kind of
ascribe too much like sophisticated
malevolent ins
or or any intel like deep intentionality
to the whole process i think
like he's just a human being and he
likes dogs just like i like dogs yeah
right that
is i think that is literally the
reasoning behind the whole dose going
thing
there is some aspect to which i mean the
guy
helped launch a car into space
right like you could you could ask like
what is the purpose of that
i think the purpose of that is uh fun
there i think he truly is more and more
especially
lately embodying the whole idea that the
most
the most entertaining outcome is the
most likely and he's fully embracing the
most entertaining outcome
and in many ways dogecoin is the most
entertaining cryptocurrency
as cryptocurrency becomes more and more
impactful in the world
people are getting more and more serious
about it and so he's selecting the
cryptocurrency that is the most
the least serious and the most fun and
there's something to that
like coupling fun with uh technological
sophistication
um and somehow figuring out a way to do
that absolutely to do that well
you know i i i want the world to be fun
i think the world being fun is great
you